today's show is sponsored by marilyn
manson's fancy dancing this is the
technical difficulties we are playing
citation needed I have an almost
randomly selected article from Wikipedia
in front of me and these folks can't see
it every fact they get right is a point
and a ding and a special prize for
particularly good answers which is now
sometimes the random article selector
comes out with something that I
definitely can't use sometimes it comes
out with something wonderful and
sometimes it comes out with something
like the Necker vest I'm nuclear power
plant deck your vest is very very young
like a vest just drive down warming like
a vest nominate I found out what the
German for the neck nominate was it's
beer nominee Evan ah yes lovely yeah
it's got that gun fastenings in it that
really really solve it neck nominate be
a nominee ROM hunts it still worked
yeah it still works on neck vest neck
your vest nominate you have to build a
nuclear power plant in your back garden
other thing you just have to wear a
really bad sweater for the next guy
really tight eighties tank top like
thing sorry just curse me the like
Starfleet spandex uniforms don't really
fit all body type so just that's a fair
point you never saw a fat Starfleet
captain I was having back what about
Scotty nowhere he didn't wear like the
the first version next generation ones
another really tight I can see that yeah
they did they did fit didn't they he
might've been a bit of a chunkier fella
in one of them just the gut hanging out
I suspect that term enough TNG
conventions have brought us yeah I Spit
my uniforms Oh again oh yeah haha
he just improvising a 76 from home or
the USS Enterprise carry on enterprise
yeah Oh actually that would have been
really good what yeah carry on Star Trek
could actually have been the thing it's
around about the right time goodness I'm
glad we're riffing on this because
frankly NECA vest I'm nuclear power
plant don't
doesn't have that much in the way of its
ownership no it's in Germany I can
anyone tell me it's nameplate capacity
nameplate Goepper late dozens and dozens
of name plates in there but a lousy
nuclear putting name badges into a
nuclear reactor that sound like the
worst thing you could do 50 name plates
per square meter when you got a name
like that you must oh just right right
to the edge of the you know in this
place looks exactly like one off
Thunderbirds so it's got a big circular
sphere thing in the middle and when they
named that log yeah going all the way
around the if I'm giving you a point
that is pretty much exactly what it
looks like hey um they want to tell me
what nameplate capacity is I'd further
over know yeah any point is it it's the
nominal capacity it's the maximum it can
put out sustained it's it's your Star
Trek reference again maximum warp
oh I see about 2.2 gigawatts of course
uh-huh yes what I was going to shot it
yeah I've got it it's hard to generate
interesting questions about nuclear
power plants let's let's go a bit more
Jeannette happen if you we in the react
that's an interesting question about a
nuclear panel it falls into the coolant
into the reactor via a pipe okay I'm not
talking about opening the top up and
just weighing in there I know exactly
that a jet of neutrons will come out and
turn my dick into Godzilla oh I think we
should all just take a breath and
appreciate that what we're actually
seeing is a remake of Godzilla just with
a tiny Branum person we're very high in
the shot go oh I shouldn't have pissed
him however you pronounce it
no no don't destroy Tokyo we neither
you look like an amazing rod holder Neve
you ha and what if rod Holland pissed
into a nuclear reactor would EMU have
come real no would he who can weld it to
his arm and sentian folks if we do have
any experts in nuclear maybe more indeed
in rod hull yeah just to tell us what
would have I mean I'm imagine it'll
basically like pissing on the stones
Nisour not only a thousand times worse
yeah and then if you have got an emu on
your hand it comes real I basically got
foresight to bring an emu with a crowd
like would naturally radioactive piss
steam essentially it comes also also if
you've got a real emu and your hand up
its ass it turns into a puppet ah work
cuts both ways
science is a major so anyway this
nuclear power plan yes how long has it
been operating I'm just may 1954 ok hang
on let me have a gun American oh my god
this is looking like something like
Thunder birds yep and it's a West German
is West Germany so since that's fire
Mick has been influenced by American and
British technology of the time in
nuclear reactors which is what
influenced Jerry Allen not Jerry Adams
day yeah Jerry Adams Thunderbirds
we're on dangerous Terry I'm gonna say
anything more to follow that I was gonna
let it run all oh oh you see these their
voices were provided by actors watching
the entire series being silhouetted like
the hood never comes out here Jerry
Anderson would have been influenced by
so I'm gonna say 1959-1960 I said 54 63
why not your closest points everyone
closest without going over which was
late enough that it got what that
earlier power plants may not a safety in
Britain there's got to be something like
that a following wind scale yeah yeah a
ribbon to open it with uh it was more
something that that they wouldn't have
wanted
protests protests
protests have a point absolutely right
are blocked the entrance with an 8 meter
wall how fat a wall yeah ah here
literally a a wall of breezeblocks they
brought with them we rock good I have
dance and classic price dog like that yo
ate me too long not ate me too high just
over the entrance really yeah still
Prado say yeah that's a pretty good
protest like we're not gonna chain
themselves down they said this imperial
guard that sat there sipping his nose he
snaps our coffee or whatever I don't
think security goes on nuclear power
stations are allowed might be cold
they're looking outside so that's
building a wall mmm but I do something
about that soon yeah I mean you can eat
just quite as oh hey leave it leave here
don't do that put it down there is a you
know international market for
electricity every time EastEnders ends
we have to buy in power from the
constant and French power and French
nuclear power search have to stick
another road of uranium on us don't just
enjoy God I think that's how it works
I'm not a scientist he was like
Harriet's nuclear power I'm banging
table he just bring another nuclear
brought in from the shed with you I
think it's going to go all right you got
the shams it's cold out though Manji you
see you saying this I went to York's
nuclear bunker whole day I went and did
the tour and one major gripe the guy
doing the tour pronouncing new killer
that side very very interesting is this
the one with a sign that says secret
nuclear bunker this way yeah yes right
next to the windmill as well I had a
brilliant day I had a tourist tourist
tour of Holgate windmills and bunkers
windmills and bunkers but like Bedknobs
and Broomsticks more about powered over
but it turns out they didn't have NBC
suits as a nuclear biological chemical
they didn't have the standard protection
suits so what you got is 180 civilians
trained to run this place in the event
of nuclear attack the first 60 to get
there would be loud in the other 120
were told go home to your families enjoy
I'm imagining a rather grim a version of
it to man my world oh yeah the 60 that's
not many no the 60 that are in there can
only survive for 30 days work a hotbed
system 20 hours each don't have MBC to
to go up on the roof to check the
readings the thing does can't survive a
direct-hit which is anywhere within 12
miles oh and these are the volunteers
these are the people that want to be
there
it's full of mechanical equipment so the
police had a list of engineers which
they would randomly select from and at
this point it all goes a bit Soviet
Russia because they're the police go and
invite them to join and come and help
and if they say no they're arrested and
they go along to help anyway Wow
I just don't raise the arrested person
yourself there's still ways we can do
this but it's not Vera Pell in in in
best methods of 261st person just oh
like it seems wrong to have a fast my
head burn my head the door closing just
out bounces back down the steps yeah
yeah even that awesome was the last
person runs in it reaches out and pulled
his hat back in before the door shuts
well it's really weird as well because
they do the tours on an hourly basis or
are on a quarter basis and if you're not
there when they go in you're not allowed
in they go and close off despite top
fence then they close the blast door
behind you and you go and do the tour so
when we come out having had you know
it's seriously paranoid down there it's
yeah it's like this was never used this
is the weirdest oh oh this is strange
this is should be a film says no and you
go back out and you open the blast or
not all these people on the fence just
waiting to be like Alan H threads turned
up to 11 if you guys are around on a
different Sun Deck so gonna be busy
tomorrow you'll well you'll hate it but
you'll all love it I'm sure it's great
no because it'll make me think of Fred's
yeah speaking of that bunker tour
they're still doing tall this were still
doing tours around chernobyl site yes
yeah you still well you see it's slowly
becoming more acceptable to go in there
but the roofs about to cave in no easy
no no no no no but not in terms of
Fallout only 20,000 years or whatever
before it's habitable but the
restrictions are
founded to slowly slackening so that you
can do what was a pretty impossible
tourist destination ten years ago is was
sort of their scent doing package tours
five years ago and now it's got a point
where they're opening it for filming
that is letting people in and it's
always been kind of a porous border
anyway because locals just yeah some of
the people still live in there yeah some
people refuse to move wildlife thriving
oddly oddly weirdly so you know what
fling another nuclear rod on it seems
like it's fine
stick another rod on the barbecue but
just just to drag it back to being silly
yeah yeah obviously the bunker in York
is one of the big command center bunkers
yes and it was decommission to whatever
else and was it in our SG to use the
technical term and regional C's of
government no that was the bunker over
the road which is now gone and is now a
modern build Bukka flats but it wasn't
here they're not as big as the Harrogate
one because obviously that's the backup
national whatever and but yeah there's
like 30 or 60 of these bigger ones with
the 60 people who get to wait for 30
days to go outside and die but anyway
and and they've all been sold off or
whatever else one of them you can
paintballing
oh and obviously on top of this there's
all the little three man ones that are
out in the hills and around the rural
Dover post yeah yeah well you sold off
as yeah it's all ROC
there's the nearest the nearest one for
us is in Fulford and it's somebody's
wine cellar ah yeah and there are also
people who will do packet who do let who
do package tours where the three of you
can go and be in this hole for three or
four days for a watch cycle of the roc
next filming location everybody cooped
up in one location for a time I can i'd
go spare and you imagine the mapped haha
well this is the thing about this hotbed
system you got sixty of them on eight
hour shifts 20 at a time and you
literally just plug [ __ ] idea and you
got so let your water day so you're not
gonna wash with it at that point when
the world has ended I drink my own piss
quite frankly although there was enough
there was enough to drink just about now
he would anyway so I was time to end up
to black on that Saturday my own piss
quite frankly
Finn our hearts on that new-car Michelle
rocks huh
congratulations Chris you win this one
just for talking for the long Jessica
Tori humongous young with knowledge and
I'm plum a plum alum I also have other
fruits a nuclear Pro are you've won a
piece of classical music played using
old military ordinance that's fit
Pachelbel's Canon in D until next time
that's been Matt gray that's been Gary
Brannen that's been Chris Cole it's the
end of the world as we knew it I've been
Tom Scott we'll see you next time
congratulations you made it through the
wilderness and to the credits leaves a
comment if you liked the show or better
yet tell your friends and there are more
than 30 audio episodes of our reverse
trivia podcast at Tech disco UK